the live shows start on America's Got
Talent so we talked to the host Nick
Cannon about that and his dream of
playing Richard Pryor on the big screen
one of the things like if I do get the
opportunity to you know be a part of a
dream project man just know I'm gonna
dedicate my all and do everything I need
to do my thing is like I try not to get
out there and talk about it at all and
just let let the cars lay where they may
be Nick Stevens starting to look a
little bit like Richard letting his hair
grow out a bit but for now he's gearing
up for a GT at Radio City Music Hall
with those famous high kicking ruckettes
last year I was part of the whole
high-kicking thing and I pulled up my
growing so this year I thought with to
the live shows ere Tuesdays and
Wednesdays on NBC and we've tested Nick
on how well he knows the shows for
judges it takes longer to get ready that
would have to be Howie Mandel he's
always trying to figure his hair out our
middle name
J star Howard J's that I don't know nope
it's Alan Alan hey okay I won't forget
that I love you I love you I love you
and Nick we all know your wife is Mariah
Carey but what is the name of Howie's
wife whoo this is Mandel that's what I
call it quick thinking but it's Terry
this is Mandel hey you know my husband's
name hoarse Keith okay
you made me nervous that you know my
kids names uh yes Ashby Carson and Tyler
oh come on bring it to Daddy
you